bonsoir nous sommes le f 18 avril 2016
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction est dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui le mouvement nuit debout qui
s'étend malgré les polémiques samedi
soir au pied est de la bibliothèque
universitaire de saint quentin en
yvelines plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes étaient réunies pour
participer ou assister à cette assemblée
générale citoyenne les nuits de boutiste
sont venus exprimer leurs idées à
l'image de leurs homologues place de la
république à paris l'ancien maire de la
verrière alain ajaj étaient notamment
présents en tant que citoyen soutenons
cette initiative on écoute
antonin et savannah deux étudiants qui
étaient présents donc pour cette nuit
debout à saint-quentin-en-yvelines nuit
debout c'est partout d'abord parce que
aujourd'hui on a besoin de faire société
ensemble est nu debout c'est l'occasion
de faire société ensemble de discuter de
construire et de
d'expliquer aux gens de voir enfin de
construire que les gens avec tout le
monde
quelle société on veut c'est très
important qu'on se réunisse pas
seulement place de la république parce
que quand on fait une assemblée place de
la république avec plusieurs milliers de
personnes tout le monde n'a pas le temps
de prendre la parole alors que si on
multiplie les nuits de boue dans toutes
les villes de france et dans toutes les
banlieues de france il ya davantage de
gens qui vont être amenés à pourvoir
s'exprimer
c'est ça le but l'a vu ce qu on est en
train de faire ça à l'air de partir sur
un rendez vous quotidien pouvoir
échanger et discuter et un gros rendez
vous le tout les samedis faire des
retours éventuellement sur toutes les
autres me dubout qui pourrait y avoir
que peut-être dans plein d'autres
petites villes du coin les premières
antennes du réseau d'éducation sans
frontières ont vu le jour en 2004
regroupant collectif mouvement
associatif mouvements syndicaux ou
encore des soutiens politiques leur
objectif venir en aide aux élèves
étrangers en situation irrégulière dont
les yvelines rsf a été lancée voici tout
juste dix ans en plateau odile jouanne
membre du collectif
bonsoir et avait aussi un bon soir vous
vous êtes lycéen à rambouillet
aujourd'hui en situation régulière vous
allez donner votre témoignage tout à
l'heure je vous propose tout d'abord
pour débuter cette séquence
cette séquence de venir sur le
rassemblement de ce week end à
l'occasion et des et dix ans vous étiez
réunir avec les ensembles ans originaire
du togo madeleine est en france depuis
douze ans et a obtenu ses papiers il y a
6 ans si aujourd'hui elle prend la
parole c'est pour faire part de son
expérience comme la plupart des sans
papiers elle a rencontré de nombreux
obstacles en arrivant des obstacles
qu'elle n'aurait pas pu surmonter seul
et ce soutien c'est au réseau éducation
sans frontières qu'elle est venue le
chercher
c'est très important d'organiser ce
genre d'événement pour pouvoir dire aux
autres que bah ils sont pas seuls deux
venien aussi avec le rsf
et même si ceux qui ne sont pas là et
que nous on entend les de bouche à
oreille de parler donc d'inviter les
jeunes ces jeunes ils étaient présents
venus écouter les témoignages et
chercher du soutien auprès du réseau
dans leurs démarches
à l'image de tigran arménien et sans
papiers depuis cinq ans oui mais dans
les drames démarches auprès de la
préfecture
il m'accompagne pour déposer déposer ma
demande compléter le dossier
on n'a pas vente et de se cacher et il
faut se montrer s'entraider pour y
arriver
aider les jeunes étrangers à trouver un
toit des papiers et un logement une
situation devenue beaucoup plus
compliqué aujourd'hui pour rsf
la circulaire va nous a bien aider mais
on sent depuis quelques mois un
resserrement les boulons et ça devient
de nouveau difficiles et avec la
nouvelle loi qui vient de paraître
nous aurons également plus de mal à
régulariser que du temps de monsieur
sarkozy
dix ans déjà que l'association officie
pour cette cause
une efficacité prouvée par la présence
de ces personnes aujourd'hui régulariser
venus témoigner de leur reconnaissance
odile johan membres de ce collectif rsf
dix ans après la création dans les
yvelines qu'est ce qui a changé à ce que
c'est plus ou moins difficile justement
pour ces étudiants d'obtenir leur papier
on a entendu parler brièvement dans le
sujet de durcissement ces derniers mois
alors il ya des hauts et des bas on peut
dire que grossièrement rien n'a changé
en 2006 c'était difficile en 2007 il ya
eu quelques progrès quelques reculs et
chaque année pareil donc j'irai pas dire
mieux ou moins bien j'irai pareil
et sur les dix ans justement d'action
est ce qu'on vous avez chiffré un peu le
bilan combien de jeunes vous avez pu
aider dans cette situation pas du tout
non c'est pas du tout dans notre culture
de faire des chiffres ça c'est sarkozy
qui les faisait ses quotas c'est pas
nous on peut dire que les 2006 il y
avait 200 par an dont 200 par an 200
père ou mère qui avait eu un refus et
qui nous ont demandé de l'aide et que
aujourd'hui tout cela on m'attend at il
de séjour donc dix ans après vincent
exception on peut donner un autre
exemple de chiffres si vous en voulez
c'est le groupe de jeunes quand le
deuxième groupe de jeunes celui qui est
né en 2013 avec six jeunes ils sont
maintenant 200 et on n'a pas été les
chercher
donc c'est la réalité qui fait qu' ils
nous ont rejoints on parle aujourd'hui
beaucoup de l'accueil des réfugiés et
des migrants est ce que ça a une
incidence sur votre activité votre
action pas directement indirectement
bien sûr puisqu'on ne rencontrent aussi
mais on commet s'occupe des jeunes et
des familles
d'enfants scolarisés il faut d'abord
qu'ils soient scolarisés pour autant
l'occupent est donc directement non on
ne rencontre cassure sur le terrain en
tout cas pas pour l'instant peut-être
dans les années à venir on va écouter le
témoignage peut être de 2 à eva et euro
6 ans à présent vous vous êtes
aujourd'hui en situation régulière
vous êtes au lycée basque ans et à
rambouillet vous êtes arrivé comme en
france et comment ça s'est passé le
parcours un peu du combattant pour
obtenir ses papiers
moi je suis arrivé en france en 2005 je
vais encore huit ans et je suis allée
enfin avec mes parents ma soeur elle n'a
pas précisé de quel pays vous veniez
arménien et donc chalet ou au début
j'allais ou à pigalle après on nous a
fait déménager à dreux
enfin après des parcours comme ça de de
ville en ville après ces dix ans après
que le grâce à rsf j'ai reçu un titre de
séjour
donc pour comprendre au tout début vous
alliez à l'école ou suivi une scolarité
en situation irrégulière enfin je t'ai
pas en régulière oui j'allais à l'école
mais j'ai pogné papier donc vous aviez
une inquiétude particulière on vous
rendant à l'école au quotidien aussi oui
en version de votre famille oui et quel
type dette alors justement fourni
l'association rsf au 10 juin comment
vous vous intervenez comment vous avez
pris en charge alors par exemple weiss
un exemple de beaucoup de jeunes qui
dans le cadre des lois françaises
devraient avoir un titre de séjour
arrivé à la famille à 8 ans d'ailleurs
sa soeur jumelle a été régularisée
son autre ed meyer automatique donc ces
problèmes ne viennent pas de la france
ou des lois françaises il repique tueur
mais de son pays l'arménie dans le pays
en guerre et il n'a pas voulu aller
faire la guerre pour des causes qui sont
pas les siennes
il n'a pas pu avoir un passeport valide
il est venu et qu'un passeport mais qui
était plus valide ses 18 ans donc on a
beaucoup de jeunes pour des raisons
différentes qui ont ce problème là par
exemple tous les pays d'afrique à qui on
impose maintenant des titres des
passeports biométriques qui ne peut pas
avoir leur passeport
il ya des pays qui redonne pas de
passeport
quand ils ont pas avoir dit au titre de
séjour donc on peut dire on a une
cinquantaine de jeunes qu'on a réussi à
régulariser ou qui vont être régularisés
sans passeport valide parce que leur
pays leur histoire leur famille pour des
raisons personnelles ne peuvent pas
prouver leur identité avec un passeport
donc comment à l'aide et ben ont besoin
les mobilisations voilà justement il ya
beaucoup de mobilisations comment vous
l'avez vécu en tout cas de voir un
réseau venir vous aider même humainement
com comment ça s'est passé comment vous
l'avez ressenti cette situation un grand
soulagement et beaucoup dette de la part
du réseau et ceci je pense grâce au
nouveau préfet enfin au nouveau préfet
qui a bien voulu prendre le dossier en
charge
parce qu'il ya toutes ces têtes que vous
fournissez mais il ya aussi cet aspect
humain il ya un soutien même alors ces
politiques mais ça reste aussi humain il
ya des parents voilà je vois que vous re
préciser un petit peu la façon c'est
bien sûr on va pas les produits dits
jeunes c'est plus qu'une masse qu'on
leur fait ça veut dire que on les
organise en groupe et donc veille ça
fait un an qu'il est régularisée y reste
pour aider les autres c'est rien aspect
collectif respect solidarité homophobie
citoyens à part entière
un bon petit français plus tard et pour
nous c'est vraiment important
on n'est pas uniquement comme un juriste
qui se bagarraient pour avoir un titre
de séjour comme on est vraiment dans la
construction du vivre ensemble chacun
avec ses droits vous intervenez encore
aujourd'hui auprès du réseau pour
soutenir les autres étudiants qui sont
dans le même cas que vous quand vous
êtes arrivé en france il ce réseau c'est
comme une famille
et quand on par exemple notre titre de
séjour on essaie d'aider son prochain
pour qu'ils aient aussi ce plaisir ce
bonheur de ressentir la même chose que
nous cette possibilité pour suivre donc
pour pouvoir faire les études parce que
là il est question de faire ses études
tout simplement en france juste pour
conclure quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui en termes de demande au
département des yvelines vous avez
combien de jeunes aujourd'hui vous
encadrez alors qu'on encadre
actuellement qui sont en situation
disons bientôt régulière on espère
une 40e près on espère pour tous face on
ne lâchera pas un seul dans ce cadre là
on a beaucoup de soutien
on a lancé un nouvel appel 16 avril où
beaucoup d'associations de syndicats ont
signé ça peut leur fondation parce qu'on
l'avait fait ya dix ans et à plus de
gens maintenant plus d'organisation le
secours catholique nous a rejoint les
éclaireurs est laïque nous ont rejoints
par n'ya pas d'association avec l'ue ont
à travailler en réseau qui ont rejoint
dans le soutien est précisément au
niveau des politiques notent les trois
c'est disons élus on a sollicité
sénatrice catherine tasca et député
benoît hamon et françoise descamps
crosnier donc les trois seuls élus qui
les plus débiles ou soutiennent
continuent à nous soutenir
et donc on a l'espoir on se demande
pourquoi les lois sont comme ça merci à
tous les deux d'être venu témoigner nous
expliquer la démarche de rsf donc dix
ans d'action dix ans d'action dans le
département des yvelines merci encore à
vous deux le journal se poursuit avec
quai samedi dernier en hommage aux
victimes de la catastrophe est de
tchernobyl et de la catastrophe de
fukushima une marche contre le nucléaire
elle a eu lieu à montigny le bretonneux
une vingtaine de personnes ont traversé
est la ville jusqu'au site du géant
français du nucléaire areva pour déposer
une gerbe un acte est symbolique pour
dénoncer la politique menée en france
william l trente ans après la
catastrophe de tchernobyl et cinq années
après celle de fukushima le collectif
sortir du nucléaire organisé sa
traditionnelle marche à travers montigny
le bretonneux en se souvenant on se
rappelle aussi que le nucléaire pour
nous c'est une énergie lié à la mort
c'est pas du tout une énergie qui
renouvelables en plus avec ces derniers
jours le plan pluriannuel de l'énergie
est pas du tout conforme à la loi de
transition énergétique qui a été votée
il ya quelques mois plusieurs
organisations réunis autour d'une même
lutte pour interpeller la population
lv greenpeace et partis de gauche mais
aussi les étudiants c'est aussi une
marche de la jeunesse actuelle quand on
voit l'âge des centrales nucléaires
quand on voit justement les accidents
qui se sont déroulés on a peur pour
notre avenir il faut que toutes les
occasions soit bonne pour être dans la
rue pour s'exprimer pour dire que c'est
l'avenir que l'on veut il est différent
de celui que la société nous impose
il ya de plus en plus d'études qui
montrent que la production d'énergie que
ça soit solaire ou éolien est beaucoup
plus rentable que de continuer dans la
l'énergie nucléaire vingtaine de
personnes se sont rendus jusqu'au site
areva pour déposer une gerbe de fleurs
un acte symbolique pour un mouvement qui
rassemble difficilement car selon le
collectif le nucléaire sur v pour les
français un sujet trop éloignés de leurs
problématiques quotidiennes retour à
présent sur l'élection de la nouvelle
maire de la verrière en fin de semaine
dernière nous avions proposé un long
entretien à revoir sur notre site
internet avec alain ajaj contraint à la
démission pour raison de santé écouter à
présent ce résumé du dernier conseil
municipal et la réaction notamment de
l'opposition
mais l'idée tu as donc succéder à
l'arrachage à 58 ans est professeur des
écoles ancien membre du secours
populaire des yvelines prend la tête de
la verrière arrivée au conseil municipal
en 2008 délégué à la jeunesse elle
affiche sa volonté de s'inscrire dans la
continuité du travail mené par son
prédécesseur le projet beckham c'est
quand même un projet qui nous tient à
coeur tous autant qu'on est au conseil
municipal
donc on va tous travailler dessus et
puis ce que j'ai dit dans mon discours
un le social et les jeunes ça c'est ma
préoccupation
je suis persuadé qu'avec elle que nous
avons mis en place que j'ai mis en place
pendant 30 ans et ce qui a été poursuivi
par l'âge continuera et quand même ça
par les temps qui courent je trouve que
c'est rassurant du côté de l'opposition
en revanche l'arrivée de nelly duthu
laisse perplexe on évoque un choix
uniquement politique
on s'attendait à un choix parmi ses
adjoints qui connaissent les dossiers
qui ont fait l'expérience d'un certain
nombre de gestion de dossiers municipaux
on aurait eu besoin de quelqu'un qui est
des vrais compétences surtout au moment
où la verrière à des difficultés
financières et un certain nombre de
dossiers et de d'enjeu a relevé alain
rage avait annoncé sa démission au début
du mois d'avril en raison de son état de
santé et reste néanmoins conseiller
municipal et gardera un oeil sur les
projets d'envergure notamment celui du
futur quartier garder qu'un phare de ce
journal on se retrouve demain aux
horaires habituels pour un point complet
complet sur l'information locale tout de
suite le 7-8 sport avec michael et demie
d'or